hello everyone welcome to a video on
code tech materials my name is matt and
mainly i just wanted to make this video
to say thank you or 500 subscribers it
is a milestone where youtube decided to
send me an e-mail about it so I was like
I should probably really thank my
viewers so thanks for subscribing and
for I guess just believing in me and
waiting for future content all that I
really look forward to making future
content more tutorials as always feel
free to leave comments anything you you
feel or want
I love seeing comments they help me
figure out what to do next and all of
that stuff and at some point I'll do
some sort of giveaway or something I am
still working on figuring out what I
want to do exactly or what I can
appropriately fund but I thought we'd do
somewhat of a special day a special
video today and do some unprecedented
programming humor that's right it's time
once again to visit the reddit thread
our programmer humor let's see if
there's some good memes today okay so
first of all let me just my camera and I
will say just in case we all lose track
of what's going on in the world I've got
this roll toilet paper here ready to go
ready to remind us I don't know what I
still don't understand why everybody
bought much toilet paper does anybody
understand I don't know I heard one
person say that it's like it's a
creature comfort but there's there's no
real reason like the thing that's going
around doesn't give you something that
requires a lot of toilet paper to handle
it's just hey you know anyway side point
let's get into the memes it's hard to
write so much small text in a small
panel taking a CES major small brain
taking a cs minor bigger brain going to
a bootcamp SHINee brain taking a Hindi
major to understand the Indian guy on
YouTube and unlock if in enough
oh man we all know what channel that's
talking about that's what's so funny
about this there's there's no there's no
question about exactly what they're
talking about what channel it's not mine
I'm not Hindi I speak English but it's
true why why are all the Indian guys so
good at C++ and programming you guys
study all the time is it just is it come
naturally I don't know someone explain
what why Indians are so good at
programming I don't actually think that
or actually I don't know I'm just trying
to be funny so in case anyone's confused
which they will be as I learned from
that one video I made about Joshua fluke
everybody just assumes that you're an
idiot unless you over explained but
whatever let's move on learning the
program in 2020 public class lesson one
main string system print out hello home
what's funny about that
it's useless code I don't understand
what it's humorous it's just useless
hello world code I guess I don't know I
don't really care either all right
and that solution doesn't work for you
you google above someone has the same
bug the post is not from 15 years ago
there is a solution
ooh that is literally how I feel too
it's like sort by you got a sort by date
say why do people have the problems
you're having now 10-15 years ago only
it's probably because you're using some
bad framework or old framework I don't
know but yeah this is quite relevant you
know this brings me to kind of a point
most people don't document their bugs
once they figure it out they just like
store the knowledge and move on
people don't document that stuff anymore
because I don't know why not but it's
just a pain it happens so frequently I
guess that's probably the reason is when
you're a programmer you go through this
like upwards of 20 times a day and
there's just
way you're gonna step aside and become a
documenting man for an hour document the
problem then go on the next one you just
don't have time as a programmer to do
that so you just gotta figure it out and
move on and I think the best thing you
can do is probably record your coding
and or do live coding or something like
that but even that's a little tricky I
can't I can't
consistently do that either a try I try
cursor in a precursor nice it's a good
meme no wonder I don't have access to
production me as a final year university
student me as a new grad employee at
work that is actually what it feels like
cuz when I was in my final year in
university I felt like I knew everything
I was like I'm ready I'm ready to
graduate I can tackle all this stuff
I understand all the stuff and then I
get to a job and it's like well it's
hard to it's a lot to explain I guess it
depends on the job but basically I
should have studied math more and less
programming is what I learned right away
at a job is that the math is sorta more
important than the program well not all
time but it was for me at a research
company so it just depends on your
company okay let's see this one darn it
Joey I shouldn't bash I shouldn't bash
programming language programming
languages I don't even know I don't even
know I shouldn't bash programming
languages I don't even know JavaScript
socks okay I'm not sure I fully
understand quite JavaScript sucks is the
punchline I guess it's kind of money but
you could put something else in there
like a language that people don't
actually use like I don't know just pick
one that nobody uses anymore
[Music]
okay the problem JavaScript well I don't
know that well I'm not a JavaScript
programmer but I do know that it is
considered someone of the slower
programming languages but is also one of
the easier ones so I don't know it were
it's what you need for doing web
development
really getting away around that unless
you're doing something really
complicated so generally for every
programming light what would you use pay
some kind of price which Abba script you
pay a little bit of the price of speed I
guess I'm start guessing there I'm sure
someone's gonna like over-explaining in
the comments and I know you guys all too
well
coronavirus is just a ddos well
coronavirus is this just a simple DDoS
yes so close your ports and stay home
okay that's kind of funny but I'm not
laughing too hard
pythons love Python error message C++
error message okay C Python error
messages oh dear oh dear gorgeous C
blasphemous air imagine this you you
Finnegan donki oh god that's so accurate
that is so accurate C++ yells at you in
the most concise critical ways it's like
I cannot believe that you using a Const
err here when I expect a string I I'm
not even gonna compile heck maybe next
time I'll compile and just have some
kind of crash and just give you some
bunch of bytecode error C++ come on yeah
get your error messages together
actually I don't mind I think the C++
error messages are okay sure they could
be better but I've gotten to the point
where I can generally understand him
captures are getting out of hand these
days
select all the squares with bugs oh god
how does anyone ever gonna get that
that's that's insane that is insane
post called true meme coder the
difference between Java and JavaScript
is the same as Corona beer and corona
virus I don't see the correlation other
than are they saying Corona beer good
like Java good and then your JavaScript
bad virus like corona virus I'm not sure
I understand the meme exactly but I
think their point is
Java and JavaScript are completely
different in Corona beer and coronavirus
are completely different he I don't know
you could you can mean that about any
word that has two meanings it's not a
very good very good meme if you ask me
quantum computers be like frost troll
stress I don't know how to say it I'm
not sure I fully understand the meme I
think it's because quantum computing is
known to be inaccurate and you know
always get the result you expect or
something like that so a mix between
true and false I think that's what
they're going for there it's funny that
some of these are obvious and others are
like oh it's funny but the more I think
about it the more I'm not sure if it's
actually funny or accurate and none was
learned okay let's see this what did you
do during your programming career dad
professional Stack Overflow copy-pasting
skit it's funny that the Stack Overflow
copy-pasting is a meme like as a
professional I wanna say that sure
sometimes you look at Stack Overflow but
one of the first things I learned
getting into real programming jobs is
like sure you can go to a Stack Overflow
and the documentation for how certain
parts of something work but if you need
to come up with your own unique solution
you're not gonna find that on stock
Stack Overflow so it's really only for
novices the whole Stack Overflow
copy-pasting career is for novice
programmers so I think once you get or I
should say novice engineers maybe I
think once you get to the next level
you'll find that Stack Overflow is
mostly garbage some of its good there
are still some good things there and
some good answers but for the most part
it's it's not a very reliable source to
bet your job on lol
trusting autosave manually saving once
or twice to make sure okay I don't know
why that's someone spent time on that
but okay the best way to learn to code I
want a code but I don't know how to get
started this hits so close to home
because I know people like this too
oh I'd love to I'd love to code or I
wish I could do what you do you
literally just sit at a computer and try
and eventually you'll get that there
isn't really nothing else to it
you just have to try like how many of
those people that say they want to do it
actually try none if they just tried
they wouldn't have to say oh I'd like to
they could just do it and as you can see
this person is mad about this whole
scenario but they're happy when they say
they want to know how then you tell them
how and they're like like this it's very
accurate very accurate yes being a
programmer takes a lot of time you're
gonna learn a lot of things are useless
everywhere else but you get a better
sense of logic I think in the long run
so it's worth it when you fix your
broken code without even figuring out
what the problem was mystery shack hack
this picture this [ __ ] is so good only
see it larger um yeah I don't really
know what to say about this image other
than sometimes that happens I usually
figure out what the problem is but there
have been times when my code was
suddenly fixed and I wasn't sure I guess
it's bound to happen you know once or
twice but most of the time when your
codes broken and it's not doing what you
expect chances are you're doing
something that doesn't work or you're
doing it wrong or miss reading something
I don't know how many times I've linked
stuff wrong like I'll go to change a
health bar and for some reason I'm
accidentally editing the wrong bar
function and then I'm like why isn't it
working and I go look again I'm like oh
I'm editing the wrong function so it's
just like
it's not a mystery it's just a mistake
and you know it happens that's why you
got a double check rediff make good
variable names make good function names
that helps the only way to hack NASA not
original content how does a hack
successfully why is this funny no it's
just anything someone literally just
made some print line code that says
hacking NASA and that's humor I'm not
sure I understand what humor is it's
just you could type anything there that
looks like a fake anything and why is
this funny I don't understand why it's
on programming humor or why someone
thinks it's hilarious
okay freelancers how do you endure the
quarantine that's my secret captain I've
always been in quarantine yeah feels
like that when you're working from home
has the format spread on here yet
Java no you can't use pointers they are
dangerous and produce many bugs hi and
star P goes burrow I don't understand
this meme what's okay well I kind of
understand it but I don't understand
what's funny about it like why would
this cause someone to laugh I don't know
the faces are the funniest thing the
words and whatever heck they're trying
to say is not funny
yeah that's Java yeah that's C++ what do
you wish that's fun why isn't funny
they're just different languages oh my
gosh people that's why I have trouble
doing these they're just they're just
they turn into programming who cares i I
don't I don't understand why these are
funny or why anyone would care some of
them are good though some we're good
okay let's see if we can get one more
good one and then I'm out
well yes I sometimes when the
coronavirus is growing exponentially
but your programs compile time
complexity still beats it easily am i
disabled that makes absolutely no sense
what is your programs complexity time
have anything to do with that yes you
are disabled whoever posted this and
laughed at it you're disabled confirmed
there are two unrelated things that's
the whole problem or maybe that's why
it's supposed to be funny I don't know
someone saved me
give me a funny one so I can quit
quarantine day ten working together
pancakes
my girlfriend me talking about get
branches yeah I'm pretty sure your
girlfriend doesn't care about you get
branches neither does anybody though
like that doesn't have to be girlfriend
you could just put any other soul in the
world and they would be more interested
in pancakes than you talking about your
git branches so pretty funny actually
but yeah it's funny cuz I made a video
not too long ago about all my gift
branches on one of my programs so it's
funny that I would say this now but I'm
just being I'm just trying to be funny
and exaggerate a little bit sure the
other people that like your project
might like git branch talk but probably
not your girlfriend alright tip for
professional programmers when the code
isn't working but you copy paste it to a
new file and it works okay from the
types that sage if only you the cutest
little thing care is pronounced as in
character care oh no it's [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not sure if I understand
this meme why are you what do you call
it Tara char is it a charcter I don't
know about I don't understand this meme
either clearly he doesn't like the way
he says car or character or char wit
does anybody really care why is this a
meme why would it why would it make you
[ __ ] it if you'd say it how it
actually should sound in the word
character instead of char or whatever
other people say can we go with it
doesn't matter again who cares all right
this one is old true CEO managers
programmer I guess it's a funny meme but
I'm not laughing because I've never
firstly felt like it was like that I
think what they're trying to say is the
programmers are really who does all the
work based on what's going on here and
the managers are like putting these
little Stoppers down I think to try to
slow down the progress and the CEO is
just I don't think I've had that
experience yet places I've worked the
managers were a lot of more also
programmers but I could see in a really
bureaucratic company that maybe the
managers would cause you more problems
it's not that funny of a meme though if
it if it does feel like that and you're
the programmer why would you work there
there should this should never happen
because if you're a programmer I would
assume you would have the logical enough
logical intelligence to not put yourself
in this position so that's why I don't
think this meme will ever truly work the
person doing this just like stays there
and
they can't complain they really can't
they're kind asking for it if you just
stay there you know don't do anything
about it
404 not found okay that's it that's a
good one
we're ending there thank you for
watching thanks again for all the
support and all the subscriptions I hope
you guys all have a safe time off or
whatever it may be for you and I hope to
see you around take care peace out Matt
out